und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend an diesem samstag drei tage loch
bis 16 mit ministerpräsident innen und
die kanzlerin entscheiden ob der
shutdown weitergeht
sie werden bis dahin nicht viel schlauer
werden als heute die kennzahlen der
pandemien steg stehen wegen der
unregelmäßigkeiten der feiertage im test
und meldesystem auf schwankendem boden
aber es spricht nichts mehr dafür dass
deutschland in den letzten wochen dem
ziel des schattens in sieben tagen
wieder weniger als 50 neue infektionen
auf 100000 einwohner wirklich näher
gekommen ist
dazu kommt nun auch noch die furcht vor
einer ansteckenden möglicherweise viel
gefährlicheren virus mutation aus
england das kann zwar immer noch eine
fehleinschätzung sein
aber eins haben die verantwortlichen
gelernt in einer solchen solche
entscheidet man sich besser für die
vorsicht sonst regiert man den nächsten
noch härteren lockdown herbei und trägt
politische verantwortung für viele tote
deshalb steht die verlängerung des
schattens in deutschland wo so gut wie
fest
andreas stamm über den brennpunkt der
schlimmsten befürchtungen großbritannien
dort wurden heute wieder fast 58.000
neuinfektionen gemeldet
sie tun was sie können und mehr 66
intensivbetten hat das centre in london
in normalen zeiten aktuell sind es 115
verfügbare räume wurden umgerüstet noch
die methode findet ihr natürliches ende
es gibt nicht mehr personal und technik
wir haben so versucht zu verhindern dass
wir irgendwann keine intensivbetten mehr
haben wir reizen alles komplett aus aber
wir haben die sorge dass wir so langsam
am ende der fahnenstange angekommen sind
in london im gesamten südwesten englands
das gleiche bild die intensivstationen
erreichen ihre belastungsgrenze oder
liegen darüber was lebensrettern werden
entscheider über leben und tod in einem
wettbewerb zu bestimmen wer ein
beatmungsgerät erhält und wer nicht
dafür hat niemand diesen beruf gewählt
das emotionale trauma für die das tun
müssen ist schrecklich niemand sollte
das machen aber wir sind an diesem punkt
großen anteil an den stark steigenden
infektionszahlen habe die neue virus
mutation die zuerst in südengland
auftauchte diese erste analyse scheint
eine studie des renommierten imperial
college nun zu bestätigen die mutation
seit deutlich ansteckender der erwert
anstieg um bis zu 0,7 hat im november
lockdown plötzlich dazu geführt dass die
fallzahlen nicht wie erwartet um 30
prozent gesunken sind sondern sich
verdreifacht haben das ist die
gravierendste mutation seit
epidemiebeginn allerdings kritiker unter
den virologen sehen in den bislang
veröffentlichten studien zur mutation
methodische mängel dass eine veränderung
des virus die übertragungsrate so in die
höhe treiben kann sei nicht ausreichend
belegt und unklar bleibt warum kommt es
in ländern in denen die mutation schon
vor wochen entdeckt wurde nicht auch zu
einem ähnlich starken anstieg am abend
kommt dann große hoffnung in kleinen
dosen der zweite inland per notfall
zulassung freigegebene impfstoff der von
astrazeneca wird ausgeliefert
gleichzeitig ändert großbritannien die
strategie die beiden vakzinen notwendige
zweite impfdosis soll statt nach drei
erst nach zwölf wochen verabreicht
werden auch wenn der schutz erst mal
geringer ist
die leute werden enttäuscht sein weil
sie auf die zweite spritze warten müssen
aber das ist nur ein kleines ärgernis im
vergleich zu den vielen leben gerettet
werden können wenn so viele menschen so
schnell wie möglich die erste dosis
bekommen
doch weder hersteller noch
zulassungsbehörde haben den geänderten
im plan je getestet pfizer etwa erklärt
ob und wie lange so ein schutz bestehe
sei unklar
tausenden patienten die schon geimpft
wurden müssen wir jetzt erklären der
zweite termin ist abgesagt und keiner
weiß genau was weiter passiert und das
beeinträchtigt das vertrauen in uns als
mediziner impfstoffmangel bei noch nie
gesehenen infektionszahlen der grund für
ein experiment des staatlichen
gesundheitsdienstes drastische zeiten
drastische maßnahmen zurück nach
deutschland wo ja auch ein großes wahl
jahr 2021 beginnt am ende wird ein neuer
bundestag angela merkels nachfolge als
kanzlerin entscheiden
und obendrein gibt es noch sechs
landtagswahlen die pandemie wird die
ganze zeit ein beherrschendes thema
bleiben
was macht das mit dem land mit den
regierenden mit dem parlament mit den
bürgern berlin direkt die wöchentliche
nahaufnahme des hauptstadt betriebswirt
sich morgen ganz dieser noch nie
dagewesenen situation widmen
in einer dokumentation von bern benthin
und lars seefeldt ein vor blick jetzt
virtueller finanzgipfel der g20 mitte
november
minister olaf scholz zugleich
kanzlerkandidat der spd sieht und hört
hier die lage in der welt es ist fast
überall das gleiche
corona zerrt an den gesellschaften bis
zum zerreißen
sap interest is too small talk areas to
disco die praxis meine überzeugung ist
dass in den reichen gesellschaften des
westens die gesellschaft mehr
auseinander läuft als das schon mal der
fall war
und das muss sich ändern
die lock down maßnahmen haben eine
nebenwirkung vereinzelung alleinlebende
haben völlig andere probleme als
menschen mit kindern jüngere andere
ängste als die älteren
die orte an denen sie sich begegnen
können sind geschlossen was macht das
langfristig mit der gesellschaft laut
einer repräsentativen umfrage des
sozialverbands caritas glaubt gut jeder
zweite deutsche dass der zusammenhalt
schwächer wird nur 17 prozent glauben er
werde stärker etwa gleich viele erwarten
keine änderungen oder machten keine
angabe ich glaube dass auch noch mal
deutlich wird dass es noch menschen gibt
die in der durch die korona panini
zusätzlich benachteiligt worden sind zb
durch die wohnungssituation durch die
schulsituation und das glaube ich hat
folgen dann für die politischen
herausforderungen ihren schönsten
ausdruck findet die gesellschaftliche
spaltung bei den sogenannten querdenkern
während die mehrheit der bürger die
antike oder maßnahmen still befolgt geht
eine laute minderheit auf die straße
bürger demonstrieren in der nähe von
verschwörungs gläubigen und
rechtsextremen unter ihnen aber auch
menschen die zwar das virus für
gefährlich halten aber die maßnahmen
nicht nachvollziehen können ist es
langfristig klug allen protest
gleichermaßen abzutun
es ist ein offensichtliches problem
einer gesellschaft und auch einen
auftrag wenn es menschen gibt die sich
nicht mitgenommen fühlen und deswegen
sollten wir nicht diese menschen
beschimpfen sondern wir sollten uns als
politikerinnen und politiker die frage
stellen was haben wir eigentlich falsch
gemacht
je länger die krise dauert desto klarer
wird wer vorher schon ein polster hatte
kommt besser durch wir bangen musste
muss es jetzt erst recht
noch kann die politik manches abfedern
durch milliardenschulden
doch irgendjemand wird sie später zahlen
müssen wer minister scholz kann sich
höhere steuern vorstellen für menschen
die mehr als 200.000 euro im jahr
verdienen
würden sie einen koalitionsvertrag
unterschreiben in dem dieser punkt
belastung der vermögenden nicht vorkommt
ich habe gesagt und wiederhole das für
mich gehört das dazu
ohne faires system der besteuerung kann
unser land gar nicht gut funktionieren
wer trägt die lasten der korona krise
dieses thema mit den wahlkampf bringen
die cdu war bisher immer gegen
steuererhöhungen aus sorge
wirtschaftswachstum zu verhindern
doch corona zwingt manchen hier neu
nachzudenken
bei weiteren ausgaben langsamer zu
machen aber zugleich die
wirtschaftskräfte
das hat die priorität und wenn das dann
dazu führt dass man noch an der
steuerbelastung verändert das glaube ich
davon geht die welt auch nicht unter
noch ist die akute gesundheitsgründen
danach wartete auf die politik eine
mindestens ebenso große herausforderung
den zerfall der gesellschaft aufzuhalten
der ganze film land im fieber die folgen
der korona krise morgen abend 19 uhr 10
im zdf nachrichten nun von gundula gause
trotz corona auflagen und ausgangssperre
haben in der britannia rund 2500 junge
leute an einer illegalen silvester party
teilgenommen
hunderte französische soll polizisten
konnten die riesen-party erst nach zwei
nächten beenden und wurden dabei auch
gewaltsam angegriffen
die techno fans feierten in einer
stillgelegten lagerhalle und hüten
keinerlei sicherheitsmaßnahmen 1 gegen
1200 von ihnen wurden bußgelder verhängt
fünf personen wurden festgenommen
im westafrikanischen niger haben
bewaffnete an der grenze zu mali
mindestens 56 menschen getötet und mehr
als 20 verletzt
die genauen umstände der attacke sind
noch unklar in der region sind etliche
islamistische terrorgruppen aktiv die
regierung in teheran hat angekündigt
mehr uran als bislang noch höher
anreichern zu wollen
das teilte iran offiziell der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde mit
seitdem us-präsident trump das
internationale atom abkommen vor
zweieinhalb jahren einseitig auf
kündigte und neue sanktionen gegen
teheran in kraft setzte hält sich auch
iran immer weniger an die
internationalen vereinbarungen
erstmals in der amtszeit von donald
trump hat der us kongress ein veto des
us-präsidenten überstimmt auch mit den
stimmen zahlreiche republikaner
trump hatte sich gegen das gesetzespaket
zum verteidigungshaushalt gestellt das
militärbudget von 740 milliarden dollar
kann nun am präsidenten vorbei in kraft
treten damit wird auch der geplante
truppenabzug zum beispiel aus
afghanistan gebremst und die verlegung
von us soldaten aus deutschland wird
ebenfalls vorerst gestoppt
der wintereinbruch hat nicht geholfen
weihnachten hat nicht geholfen auch der
jahreswechsel nicht das schicksal von
fast 1000 migranten und flüchtlingen
hauptsächlich aus afghanistan oder
pakistan versinkt bei lieber an der
grenze der europäischen union zwischen
kroatien und bosnien herzegowina immer
tiefer im edlen tiere lage ist
hoffnungslos weil keiner der politischen
akteure ein interesse hat ihn zu helfen
bosnien herzegowina
möchten sie nur los sein egal wohin
nicht zu uns tönt das eu land kroatien
verteidigt die außengrenzen der union
und prügelt jeden zurück der es über die
grenze schafft das ist dokumentiert wie
die hartnäckige weigerung bosnien
herzegowina etwas für die opfer zu tun
die sollen doch besser das weite suchen
britta hilpert berichtet
da rollt hilfe heran ins camp lieber in
bosnien herzegowina die armee bringt
zelte und decken für rund 1000 personen
doch diese zelte machen die flüchtlinge
kaum wärme kaum glücklicher sie wollen
hier gar nicht sein
und seit heute verweigern einige die
eine mahlzeit die sie hier noch bekommen
und wir nehmen heute kein essen der denn
die bosnische regierung hilft uns da war
man dort hat das gibt dir doch so viele
probleme
deswegen sind wir im hungerstreik die eu
sollte etwas tun wie liu pionieren für
den weg in die eu nehmen sie dieses
leben auf sich ohne heizung strom
funktionierende toiletten hier in der
nähe wollen sie heimlich die grenzen
überwinden aber in kroatien werden sie
zurück geprügelt die eu will sie nicht
seit jahren geht das so neu ist dass
auch die bossen ja sie nicht wollen
immer wieder blockieren sie
flüchtlingsunterkünfte der staat kann
sich nicht durchsetzen
das flüchtlingsproblem schwächt das
zerrissene bosnien-herzegowina weiter
wenn ein staat eine entscheidung in
einer region über migranten
untergebracht werden sollen nicht
durchsetzen kann dann ist es natürlich
eine ermutigung für all jene die seit
jeher ein schwachen start rollen oder
den staat sogar zerstören wollen
weiterzumachen europa schickt geld um
flüchtlingsunterkünfte zu schaffen
trotzdem nimmt der unmut zu gegen
migranten und gegen die eu
denn die migranten kam aus der eu aus
griechenland und wollten in die eu
sie sind ein eu problem meint man hier
bosnien hercegovina fühlt sich als
europas abstellgleis für unerwünschte
sowohl innenpolitisch schlechtes den
start erst recht unterstützung für die
europäische union es schafft auch
unzufriedenheit und auch spannungen zu
den migranten vor ort und all das ist
eine situation die sich eher
verschlechtern wird in den kommenden
wochen und monaten
sie haben heute holz ins camp lieber
gebracht lastwagenweise der winter steht
noch am anfang und den verbringen sie
wohl hier
kein blieb aber bleibt ein problem so
wie die ganze europäische
flüchtlingspolitik ein paar armee zelte
ein paar millionen euro ändern daran
nichts
und noch einmal nachrichten und service
wie immer ansonsten trotz corona zieht
es viele ausflügler hier in deutschland
und in den alpen in den schnee in den
mittelgebirgen hat der ansturm zu teils
chaotischen zuständen geführt wie im
harz waren straßen und wege überfüllt
auch im taunus im schwarzwald oder in
der rhön wollten viele zum wandern und
radeln in den schnee die polizei rät von
solchen ausflügen ab nicht nur wegen der
kontakt beschränkungen sondern auch
wegen der staus straßensperrungen und
schneebruch und in den nächsten tagen
kann es immer wieder schneien oder
regnen
das wetter bleibt winterlich trübe
morgen liegt eine dicke wolkendecke über
deutschland vom südwesten bis nach
sachsen schneit und regnet es vor allem
im osten muss mit glatteis gerechnet
werden die temperaturen von minus zwei
bis plus fünf grad halten sich dazu
immer wieder schnee oder regen vor allem
vom norden bis in die mitte fehlen noch
die gewinnzahlen vom lotto sie lauten
wie immer ohne gewähr
78 16 28 30 34 superzahl 6 weitere
gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de und im zdf
text und alles vom sport jetzt gleich im
sportstudio wir sehen uns morgen wieder
ist da
[Musik]